في سماء المانيا اطلقت اهم المناورات
الجويه على الاطلاق في تاريخ حلف شمال
الاطلسي الذي يمتد لاكثر من 74 عاما 25
دوله من دول الاعضاء في الناتو واخرى
شريكه لها بما فيها اليابان والسويد التي
تتطلع للانضمام للحلف تشارك في تدريبات
23 الجويه هذه التدريبات الضخمه ستضم نحو
250 طائره عسكريه وبمشاركه اكثر من عشره
الاف جندي للتركيز على تنسيق والحمايه من
الطائرات من دون طيار وصواريخ كروس طبعا
في حال تعرض مدن او مطارات او موانئ تتبع
لدول الحلف لهجمات الناتو مصمم على الدفاع
عن كل شبر من اراضيه يقول هنا قائد القوات
الجويه الالمانيه اثناء تقديمه التمرين
مشددا على ان الناتو تحالف دفاعي غير ان
الهدف الابرز من وراء هذه المناورات
الجويه هو توجيه رساله الى روسيا ومفاده
هذه الرساله ان الناس قوي
وسيبقى كذلك
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على يوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات